plus the fight against the delta variant
of covet 19 presents many
unknowns white house correspondent peter
ducey leads us off tonight live from the
north lawn good evening peter
good evening brett officials here think
the best way to keep
the economy on the right track is to
keep getting as many people as possible
vaccinated and there are now staff level
conversations about possibly starting to
withhold
federal funds from places that don't
require federal workers
or people that are getting federal money
to get vast the biden plan is working
the president is taking credit for
july's jobs report
943 000 added exceeding estimates
as the country claws back from covid
we're in a dark winter
with real concerns about what spring
would bring
but then we got to work cabinet
officials are pleased
it's not perfect but it is a good news
story that's because the economy is
still nearly 6 million jobs
short of where it was before covid this
is not a normal recession
this is not something that's predictable
and i think as we think about moving
forward
so i think as we continue to get more
people back into the job market
seeing we need to see more wages rise as
well we saw four percent
increase in wages for people which is a
good thing prices are rising more
though leading to renewed concern about
inflation
we've all been talking about this wage
inflation right
as wage inflation kicks in that is the
thing that could take
transitory inflation and make it longer
lasting or potentially make it
permanent variants may be trending in
the wrong direction but
economic trends are unaffected for now
we haven't seen to date
a direct impact on the economy from
delta still the white house wants every
state to stick
to strict cdc guidelines and they are
running into resistance
from republican governors like ron
desantis
now desantis is firing back i guess the
question is is what else
has he forgotten biden's forgotten about
the crisis at our southern border i can
tell you that
biden has forgotten about the inflation
that's biting the budgets of families
all throughout our country
and desantis is threatening to withhold
funds from school districts that require
students
to wear masks he says that his concern
is about harmful emotional academic and
psychological effects of putting
kindergarteners and masks
for hours at a time is there any concern
from officials that you guys talk to in
your
early pre-decisional discussions about
that
no there's not i also had a chance to
ask her
why if the economy is growing and
creating historic numbers of jobs in the
first couple months
the president is still pushing for these
massive relief
programs like the ban on evictions and
she basically said that is because
even though there was a good jobs report
there are still just too many people out
of work right now
right well to that point peter the
administration today extending the pause
on student loan payments
what they have to say about that yes the
education secretary cardona is
explaining that's because they want
people instead
spending their money and focusing on
their families and their health that
student loan pause was set to expire at
the end of next month now it's going to
run through the end of january 2022
progressives want the president to go a
lot further and just go
cancel up to 50 000 of student loan debt
per borrower but the president has not
expressed a willingness to go that far
yet right